à quoi ressemblera le carnaval 2021
il faut faire carnaval autrement alors
que les parades de rues ont été annulés
se contenter d'une parade dans un lieu
clos cet hommage parce qu'on pourra pas
s'amuser malgré les interdictions des
groupes à pied s'organise défilent et
rassemble des centaines de personnes au
mépris de la loi
à quelques semaines des traditionnelles
festivités est les pour et les contres
s'affrontent
il faut pas ya le carnaval par rapport à
la maladie qui circulent un peu partout
pas aussi protéger nos proches le
carnaval 2021 le crève coeur d'une
population résonance hashtag droit de
suite mardi à 20h10 sur martinique la
première